la négociation est là c'est un
euphémisme ce que dit sylvie goulard et
je sais qu'elles le pensent en plus un
peu comme moi il ya un déficit
démocratique majeur dans le
fonctionnement le parlement a donné un
mandat à la commission la commission
négocie elle tord le parlement dans la
précédente mandature et les verts
d'ailleurs ont voté contre
donc certains sont abstenus mais le
problème qu'on a c'est que la commission
négocié de manière totalement opaque
ouais on n'a pas accès aux documents ou
à peine enfin je veux dire il ya sais
pas ce qui se passe on sait pas ce qui
se passe les négociations se font de
manière on est on a des documents dans
une data room c'est une salle de lecture
on peut pas prendre en photo à bronzer
bref passons mais un déficit
démocratique majeur et c'est toujours
très dangereux pourquoi est-ce qu'on
cache et chose pourquoi est ce qu'on ne
sait pas ce qui se négocie et pourquoi
on ne sait pas sur quel mandat les
choses ce n'est pas l'un justement
là-dessus à ce propos c'est matthias
fekl secrétaire d'état au commerce
français qui a exactement la même
position vous oui il écoute
il est inacceptable que des enjeux
fondamentaux soit négocié en secret et
en opacité la france ne l'acceptent pas
ne l'acceptera pas et ne l'acceptera
jamais gelé indiqué encore récemment au
haut représentant du président obama
nous souhaitons des évolutions sur ce
sujet si rien ne change dans un avenir
raisonnable c'est-à-dire dans les jours
qui viennent
au 11e tour de négociations et dans le
courant de l'année 2016 la france en
tirera les conséquences demandera
l'arrêt des négociations et nous
travaillerons avec nos partenaires
européens en ce sens alors sylvie
goulard je me tourne vers vous est ce
que vous diriez que matthias fekl est
hypocrite puisque il s'agit donc d'un
mandat de négociation qui a été aussi
négocier avec les états on peut le dire
on n'est pas au nez sur un sujet pas de
remarques la première pour vos auditeurs
est la négociation d'accords
internationaux est une prérogative de
l'exécutif ok quand le quai d'orsay
négocier avec l'iran j'ai pas vu
monsieur fabius venir expliquer cartes
sur table ce qui se passe il ya toujours
eu une opacité qu'on peut combattre mais
j'aimerais qu'on la combattent
autant au niveau national qu'au niveau
européen on laisse en tant que c'est
l'europe qui fait les choses de manière
vague j'ai commencé ma carrière dans la
diplomatie
j'ai toujours été impressionné par la
capacité de secret des diplomates après
il ya une autre aspect qui selui
tactique
quel est notre intérêt vis-à-vis des
américains jusqu'où peut-on aller dans
la transparence que je souhaite mais qui
doit être aussi une transparence habile
si vous abattez votre carte dans une
négociation même pour quelqu'un qui
achète un appartement on sait très bien
qu'à un moment dans la négociation de la
part de bluff
il ya toujours une part de bluff donc il
ya un enjeu démocratique il ya un enjeu
tactique il faut aussi et d'abord de la
compréhension pour les deux s'empêche
pas de chercher d'en faire plus ce
monsieur fait qu'elle je crois peuvent
faire une meilleure explication comme la
commissaire peut faire une meilleure
explication alors pascal durand et
écouter ce que ce qu'a fait monsieur
fekl c'est tout simplement qu'il a
entendu les populations et il a compris
à une tare d'opportunisme politique
il ya aussi une part d'intelligence
politique s'est noyé hier qu'il a
compris que les populations c'est comme
les ogm c'est comme sur d'autres sujets
à un moment les gens disent non on n'en
veut pas les tribunaux arbitraux le fait
qu'on puisse pas contrôler de manière
alors bien sûr qu'il ya des parties des
négociations qui doivent être secrète
qui donne mais bien sûr mais là c'est
l'ensemble est secret donc ça n'est pas
possible le mandat de négociation a été
enlevée le mandat et les mairies mais le
mandat il a été donné on nous a donné le
mandat avec des mois et des mois de
retard une fois que de toute façon il
était quasiment publiques lassées on est
toujours en décalage mais le problème je
répète il ya un déficit démocratique
majeur mais par ailleurs la question la
vraie question c'est pourquoi faut-il
actuellement négocié les normes web
encore une fois avec les états unis
alors que nous ne sommes pas au clair
nous mêmes sur nos pros versements sur
la première puissance commerciale mais
lang adhérents et aux états ont lié au
fait de conclure mais les accords liant
ainsi déjà avec les états unis ça marche
très bien
non c'est un majeur et dernier c'est 50%
quasi lisait le même talent produisent
des appellations pour la paille est de
ces graves pour les agresseurs les les
entreprises qui n'ont pas accès au maroc
est très grave pas d'accord avec les
lames alliance de lutter contre
l'agriculture intensive les vous êtes
aussi défense parce que les américains
ont dénombré bataller c'est ça les
problèmes vous me demandez les autres
droit social sur les chinois en moi ces
thèmes il le ferait bon pas fait ce qui
me frappe si l'adversaire du type note
battue moi je n'en étais pas battu avec
défendre là le jeu veut défendre les
valeurs européennes et bien si on est
d'accord et d'écouté comme aligné sur le
réseau social durant sylvie goulard
merci on vous mettra pas d'accord mais
moi je vous donne rendez-vous essayons
de négociations on est d'accord